in a couple minutes I'm gonna tell you
why we might care about this first but I
actually want to not just look an
example of this I want to prove that
this is not just a coincidence I want to
see that this always happens okay
so underneath this make a little
subheading for me and call this
generalization because what you just had
a look at with something specific a
particular polynomial and what
particularly happens with those numbers
now I want to look at something general
what happens with any quadratic no
matter what the numbers are
okay so I'm gonna call this P of X
instead of having numbers like 315 and
18 our general quadratic would be a
because it could be anything and B and C
so I'm gonna write it like so it's x
squared plus BX plus C now I went
through this process of factorize that
and I got two zeros out of that and then
I named the zeros I called them alpha
and beat up because this could be any
pollen or any quadratic I like right I
don't know what alpha and beta are I
don't know if they're negative 2 and
negative 3 or 1 and 8 or who knows what
they are okay so all I can call them is
alpha and beta so I'm just going to say
let the zeros of this particular
polynomial this quadratic let them be
alpha and beta okay now what I want to
do is write this new quadratic in terms
of alpha and beta where are alpha and
beta in my rewriting of the polynomial
here they are yeah and here right so if
you knew what the zeros were that would
tell you what the factorization was
right so I can rewrite P of X like so in
a factorized form what would be the
factorization
have a look at how we set this up right
I'll give you a clue there's gonna be
some X's in here right
what follows what follows after this if
for example you had some polynomial any
polynomial and its roots were 1 & 2 1 &
2 what would the factorization look like
X hmm it's gonna be a 1 and a 2 in here
right a 1 and a 2 what's going to go in
between think carefully
the zeros are 1 positive 1 & 2 positive
2
this is give me a minus sign in between
there right because think about this
first part here if I put x equals 1 into
here but that becomes 0 which is the
whole point then I don't care what the
other thing is because 0 times anything
is 0 and the same thing with this if
that's if I put in x equals 2 right then
I will get that now I don't actually
know that there 1 & 2 well I think they
are alpha and beta right so I'm gonna
call these guys alpha and beta are you
ok with that
yep looking good there's just one small
problem
have a look back at what we did you guys
factorize this for me you told me this
is what we ended up with there's a piece
in this line that's are missing in that
line over there do you see what's
missing yeah this guy the front right
where he come from
it was the coefficient of what the
coefficient of where we get from yes the
coefficient of the leading term which
why we call it the leading coefficient
right so where does it belong over here
it just belongs at the front here does
that make sense
hey now just think about this for a
minute before we leave off this ID here
notice please that a could be anything
it could be 3 could be 1 it could be
negative 2 800 and the zeros would still
be a from beta do you see that like you
can change this however you like and
you'll still get the same answers okay
now here comes the magic I want to prove
these two guys I want to prove that what
happens when you add up these two roots
you'll always get that when you multiply
these two roots you'll always get this
right so what I'm gonna do switch an
orange because this is me talking about
these results now I'm going to take this
guy and make it look more like the
original line and try and do a can
Harrison okay this is factorized that's
expanded so let's see what happens when
I expand this right Oh am I gonna get
I'll deal with this guy first if you
were to expand this this is in terms of
alphas and betas right I don't have to
do first outside inside last that's
normally how I expand things like that
so x times X okay next time mortgage
let's write down X minus this guy times
this so minus beta X so I've dealt with
the first guy what should be the next
thing that I write minus Alpha X so
you've transitioned over this that right
there last time very good the negatives
cancel don't think this is what you get
on the end okay start expanded this is
good but I want to go one more step
further it's one less that are maybe to
have a look I've got an x squared term
just like I want it over here I've got a
constant term as well just like I've got
over here
but then I've got I got two x terms and
I kind of just want to have one so how
will I turn these two into one I'm gonna
factorize out this common X you see that
so let's write the next name here we go
x squared that guy's fine there's no
collecting of like terms that you can do
with this guy but in between here have a
look if I take out my common factor of X
what do you get left with you get beta
and you also get alpha now you can see
I've written a minus sign here as well
so therefore I'm gonna get alpha plus
beta I know it's a little unusual when
we factorize things out we usually write
them at the front but when we write X is
we usually write them on the end so even
though I'm factorize here I'm putting it
at the back of that term okay and then
here's my last one right there
so two right yeah okay here comes the
magic right
what is this polynomial it started off
as this general guy here ax squared plus
BX plus C that's what this is I'm just
looking at it a little bit differently
okay so now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to divide everything through by a
because that's going to
looking a lot nicer and simple for me
okay so let's let's just do this guy
first if I divide this ax squared by 8
what do I get
just x squared just by itself I've got
to divide everything through by a right
you can't just choose particular things
so if I divide this guy by a as well
what do you get B over a so I'm dividing
that part B is the coefficient and then
there's still an X there do you agree
with that that's okay and then the last
term on the left hand side see you every
dude those guys look familiar at all I
should right okay what do I got on my
right-hand side over here I just have to
write it without the a right cuz I just
divided through by a so I'm just gonna
write everything over here x squared
minus this guy plus this guy all right
now I know it just looks like a lot of
algebra at the moment okay but what have
we just said what you're looking at is
the same object B of X right but you're
looking at it kind of from two different
angles same thing right this is from the
point of view of just what were all the
coefficients and this is from the point
of view of what are the zeros same
object inspected from two sides let have
a look here what's a good color finish
right there's an x squared here right
and unsurprisingly there's an x squared
over here and they look the same you're
like these two things are equal to each
other no big deal but then have a look
at this guy here see that it has an
equivalent a match on the other side do
you see it
what's it matched up to its hold on wait
this is the X term right yes term so it
matches up to this guy do you agree with
that do you see like they're kind of
like twins right these are the only X
terms on the left and these are the only
X terms on the right so if they're
equivalent to each other doesn't it
stand to reason that be on a X this guy
left it equals that whole thing
underneath there or above my squiggly
line right minus alpha plus beta X do
you create that like there's no other
thing there's no other place you get X
terms from the left or the right so
these guys are like twins right we can
simplify this a little bit can't we
I don't need to write the exes there
it's really these two things that are
really interesting right so I'm gonna
write be on a equals this what's the
last step I should do to get to my
actual result that I wanted I should
divide through by a negative 1 or
multiply through by that you're on same
effect it's in it right so I'm gonna
write alpha plus beta equals minus B on
a whatever a and B happen to be whatever
alpha and beta happen to be not just
negative 2 and negative 3 for any values
like I don't even have any numbers here
no Numerical numbers anyway I have
printing rules right
okay so this is a result called this
summer fruits so what happens when you
add up the roots no matter what they are
you get this guy okay
I'm not going to finished am i there's
not just the summer fruits there's also
that the product of roots can you see
the product of roots over here on the
right hand side there he is right there
okay so I'm gonna put a box around it
what is its matching term on the left
hand side see a right in fact this is
even easier you can pretty much just
write straight away from these two
things when you take alpha beta on the
right hand side it very directly equals
that guy C on a that's the only constant
term on the left everything else has
like we'd exes sort of tied up within it
okay but this is a constant term a
number like say for example six it's
just a number and then this is just a
number right negative two times negative
three so these results that you've just
proved right this is the proof of the
result this is the sum of roots and this
is the product of roots okay now to
illustrate why this is interesting that
why do we care about this can I ask you
to get your laptop's out and pull open
desmos for me